Your Royal Highness, Meghan Markle, congratulations to you both.
Thank you.
Can we start with the proposal and the actual moment of your engagement?
When did it happen, how did it happen?
It happened a few weeks ago, early this month, here at our cottage.
It's a standard, typical night for us.
It's a cozy night.
What were we doing?
Just roasting chicken.
And it was just an amazing surprise.
It was so sweet and natural and very romantic.
He got on one knee.
Of course.
Was it an instant "yes" from you?
Yes, as a matter of fact, I could barely let you finish proposing.
Can I say "Yes" now?
She didn't even let me finish, she just said, "Can I say 'Yes'?"
And then there was hugs and I had the ring on my finger,...
... and I was like, "Can I give you the ring?"
She was like, "Oh yes, the ring!"
So you know, it was a really nice moment, it was just the two of us...
...and I think I managed to catch her by surprise as well.
Yeah.
And this is how long after you first met?
It would be a year and a half, two a little more than that.
No, just probably about a year and a half.
How did you first meet?
Yes, we first met, we were introduced actually by a mutual friend,...
...and then we met once, and then twice back-to-back, two dates in London...
...and last July,...
Yes.
...beginning of July, and then it was, I think about three maybe four weeks later...
...that I managed to persuade her to come and join me in Botswana...
...and we camped out with each other under the stars...
...and we spent, she'd come to join me for five days out there, which was absolutely fantastic.
So then, we were really by ourselves,...
...which was crucial to me to make sure that we had a chance to get to know each other.